et R dos de Jurgen Pauls les
drapeaux français flottent ici en C car c'est
r pod maintenant pour la France individuel Cavalier
à bord du rough marin de Pepe 53ème des
82 pour
démarrer ce cheval de 8 ans appartenant à
Van cin et Moselle Valerie anoc cost
et le  Les Français adoreraient obtenir un
bon score, mais ils ne sont pas tout à fait leurs
concurrents jusqu'à présent. Cody a tellement d'
attentes pour un peu de problèmes lors
de la promenade,
il regarde ce
grand écran au-dessus de sa tête et c'est quelque
chose que vous ne vous attendiez pas vraiment à
un si grand écran.  écran qui est
idéal pour notre visualisation mais pourrait juste être
un peu une distraction pour les chevaux
juste au-dessus du point central pas
facile probablement pas à plus de 2 moi au-dessus de
la tête du cavalier
ouais un vrai plafond au milieu de
l'arène car Pep est un dur  marin
dans la première vrille Bon départ léger
renversement Cod Yen exactement tu deviens
un bon juge Ed merci Cody
parce que j'ai eu de bons
professeurs donc Ronell Port qui est un
marin rude se tient debout, ils aiment voir
que les juges le cheval  peut faire un
mouvement d'adrénaline puis rester calmement en
attendant la prochaine commande du
cavalier pas de renversement là-bas même si c'était parfait, ils ont
fait du bon travail
là-bas, ce gars est un double champion de France
étant également champion de France de maturité l'
année dernière à Léa  ici à Normy a remporté l'
open nrha et aussi la compétition amateur Elite en
mars pour ce deuxième tour,
chaque juge avec un bonus A plus demi, il a
gagné des crédits sur les deux manœuvres et les deux
tours, mais ils ont pénalisé ce premier
tour comme nous l'avons vu d'ici  donc
il est assis à 70 et demi en entrant
dans sa première série de cercles un grand
bruit de cette foule française les cris
résonnent autour de ce stade pluvieux alors que rp
va à la fin de ses cercles gauches deux grands
rapides et un plus petit plus lent Cercle
la transition vers  le cercle lent n'est
pas aussi net que nous le souhaiterions,
mais le changement de vol Cody était net comme
vous aimez le changement de vol était en
plein milieu, avançant ici gentiment sur
ce cheval LGE F cherchant un peu l'extérieur,
donc juste  Cirles pour R il a plutôt
bien commencé le Français qu'ils ont vu aussi comme un
spectacle de Pâques à Cyon en Allemagne cette année
était premier et deuxième Ron
Walz petit cercle changement de leader encore
assez bon assez bon assez bon
changement de leader juste vous auriez pu améliorer le
ralentissement juste un  un peu sous la pluie,
le cheval recule et euh quand
vous tirez un peu sur le Range, c'est
autorisé, c'est sûr, mais c'est difficile pour les
juges de donner du crédit à la
manœuvre du port s'il peut vraiment
réussir ces arrêts, il a obtenu un  la chance de
se qualifier pour la finale aujourd'hui ou
jeudi était une belle descente il est allé il a
parcouru un long chemin dans l'arène et
les juges aiment voir une bonne descente
construire une vitesse constante sur la course
maintenant très bonne
descente plutôt bonne  arrêtez le cheval qui n'est pas
capable de tenir le sol à nouveau, nous
avons des problèmes avec ces crachats aujourd'hui
et c'est à ce moment-là que vous voyez les pattes arrière
se briser, puis ils sautent en
avant pour une deuxième pause en deux phases
exactement s'ils peuvent tenir ce terrain  la
force, la force dans le haut de gamme, la
force à l'arrière s'ils peuvent tenir
ce terrain et ils gagneront du crédit pour
ces
voiles difficiles de Stop qui étaient un peu
mieux stop, c'est sûr ouais jusqu'à la fin de
son P, le sol français ira  sauvage mais
un assez bon score très peu de points négatifs
Point quelques points positifs
ainsi qu'un modèle solide pour le Français, il
est très heureux et ravi Ron sauvage
pour avoir
terminé avec un joli holl au
rugueux marin de Pepe qui sort et quelle bonne
ambiance se construit dans ce merveilleux
Stade, jetez un œil à ses superbes tours
[Musique],
joli retournement autour de ce point,
gain de point,
juste les cercles l'ont
retenu, il a obtenu zéro zéro, euh, il n'a pas obtenu de
crédit dans les cercles, alors j'attends juste
le score, ici, il arrive 2 1  trois donc
22ème une chance extérieure d'être dans ce
deuxième lot de qualification 30 places ou
mieux passeront à la deuxième
compétition de qualification jeudi
ne va probablement pas vraiment le faire Cody
ouais, j'espère que nous pourrons voir certains des
coureurs français en individuel  des finales
qui seront formidables pour le
public local seraient certainement excitantes car l'
excitation monte déjà alors que nous nous
approchons du déjeuner du
deuxième jour des Jeux équestres mondiaux btech fbii pour la
première fois que cela